Jordan Rogers and a Jojo Fletcher in  disguise it's crazy to me here's the pic  the couple rocking out of control wigs  it's a throwback to when they had to  keep their relationship a secret  while the Bachelorette was airing Jordan  captioned the shot the last time we were  in Chico together you might have met our  alter egos at Goldy and Ricky oops  hashtag sneaky fish Tagus sorry ABC  apparently disguises were a regular  thing for the pair at that time they  told ET this story after the  Bachelorette finale aired there was one  time we were we were in LA for a couple  of days separate and so I borrowed a  buddy's Halloween costume mullet wig and  a trucker hat and took it over to her  hotel and was kind of sleeping around a  little bit but now the couple is hanging  out in plain sight as themselves  the duo sweetly celebrated Jordans  birthday with an early morning hike in  his hometown of Chico California on  Tuesday